my friends were playing in a volleyball
tournament and I played in this
tournament last year but this year I
signed up too late I couldn't get in or
whatever and I heard that dudes were
playing in this tournament now they
might have been there last year but I
just wasn't paying attention so maybe
they were maybe they weren't
um but I wanted to go see so I went to
this tournament I saw a bunch of dudes
playing
um and I took interviews I got girls
opinions a lot of people were afraid to
say anything right because they don't
want to get in trouble uh and I also got
people that agreed with them playing's
opinions so I really was interviewing
both sides everyone that I interviewed I
had expressed permission to interview
so then what did I do next oh and I also
got footage of them playing just you
know is it fair I don't know